Again a lot. I should explain it a bit like this. I'm an economist and a researcher and.
I know what you can do with statistics. Statistics you use to package different face.
And you can do it any way you want to so you can look at bill and cliff as a village.
And you can brush it with the tar. Of welfare dependency and say look this cost the taxpayer so much money.
And it is being done at the same time.
That look at the other side the reason why the word welfare dependency here was it was created by systematically
withdrawing any asset we had. Into local council conditions including five million dollar. Bridges.
Hundred fifty thousand dollars.
Roads and this and the amount of cost so we never could build a commercial infrastructure that was denied.
Secondly even if it wouldn't have taken place. You must value.
A model that can make out a one hundred thousand dollar property. A ten million dollar property within ten years time.
Each and every individual who had no money ten years ago.
Now has got a home worth fifty sixty seventy thousand dollars in income but by the banking system. We changed.
Property. As john said it could not support one farmer family. Could not so we had to walk off the land.
And now it's supporting eighty families and in time. Well one. That adds to the national assets. Ten million bucks.
Which is a lot more than distillate ever got into so security receipts and secondly it actually.
Just a very thing that. Everybody's talking about now which is. Ecologically sustainable development.
You're nurtured the earth brought in poison it. You take control of your own life or and having it rules. It.
You produce your own products to import them. And you feed the community values are they a people hear more.
By more of their own. Become less dependent on exports. Less depend on the motor car and.
Bring tourist dollars in by sharing. Other people how to do this. This is what.
Stage in this latest deal is all about now we've gone for and we've gone for a cow with. Processed food dried food.
From nursery. At a nursery.
And then we're going for some sort of eco tours
and these other things that the infrastructure that will make it worthwhile for tourists to come here
and have a look at. Buddy year two thousand and. It will be very very difficult. To buy into berlin cliffs.
Very difficult it will be family plots and they want to leave the family to get valuable.
It will be a training institute for this lifestyle. And will attract people who are right around the world.
Because we offer here now. All the things that we were dreaming about and you still dream about in the cities.
Which is to have a fresh air you have no payments to degrade you don't pollute the degree. You have a you grow.
Beautiful foods. And you know how to do the healing arts and so on.
So that process of ecotourism is taking place now it's a regional thing we started something which is catching fire
regionally now and it's going to into nimbin as well.
It is a topic which needs discussion at length because the community itself must put values on how much they will sell
out to the great god mammon in order to become independent right now.
We are already depend on the system as a as a lifestyle. In fact. Anything wrong with dollar couriers thing.
It is that it's been supported to the point that it is weak at the knees it can work on a more totally.
So secure dependence and to have a true philosophy for the next century and we hope an eclipse is in fact.
A leading part of days. It must. Financially independent.
You've got a role to get your side of the river you can't keep on saying. Poor theremin. Yeah. Yeah. Well i know.
Well that that has happened. And there are still a few private place. Ok. Sure.
Strata title it didn't really improve people's chances of making more money it just made it easier for people to buy.
Because on a strata title they could get a law. Whereas on a multiple occupancy you couldn't on a multiple occupancy.
Let's say a house that's for sale here for id grand and will probably be sold very quickly.
On a multiple occupancy you might be lucky and get twenty four.
Because you can't borrow money on the strength that much rather come get two or three.
Yes you would just be very lucky to get any sort of money back.
Well that was one of the when we had to go for the strata title. A lot of people didn't want that. You know.
And we had to look at all that was about five alternatives that we had to study and. The strata title came out.
As the winner. Now we knew that the offshoot of that immediately was a lot more rights because we'd have to pay.
Individual rights to lose more council. As well as our internal levees. So a lot of people didn't want it.
But it was the only way. And one of the ups of that is the forty one of the multitude of reasons.
People have to move away. They can get as much. They can get enough money to probably set themselves up somewhere else.
After a fashion rather than. Have to walk out with nothing. So distraught as we're good in that way.
It has allowed people to take a capital investment. But the ones who want to sell.
We really want them to sell and maybe somebody else comes in who doesn't want to sell. Generally people in malls or.
In places like berlin for do not want to hang on to lifestyle.
Because very little outside their you can compare it with but.
You've got to recognize something must have mainstream values
and i think one of the things that we're particularly interested in is to build a bridge between mainstream
and turn it is. Because we've got to integrate.
Where once all we are male and female inside you know you have you and yang. Fire and water. It's.
That that capitalism communism duality must go all the must be a bridge builder and that bridge.
Means that your average person can actually. Attain.
The lifestyle of society now or claim to be ecologically sustainable. Yet.
And to do that you must have a model that allows you to do so
and one of the things i like to make clear about bill implicit is when you listen to it
when this in to ourself talking it seems like an enclave of a club almost how do you get in.
How do you keep things like this not true. You come in and you go like in any order village it is no.
You don't know everybody on the property. Diverse people who are. Speculators who never are here.
There is people who are active committee members who had every meeting douras. Hermits.
There are people who work in town and don't play to look much at the village. And it's easy to get in and out.
And and and that sense to bridge is important because if you tell the average person in the city.
The world's falling apart. The bombs about to drop the financial system about to collapse.
Blah blah blah all the whole thing isn't going to do you know. There's no good. You can't do more you can't.
On that beach anymore. And you say what's your alternative well the multiple occupancy.
You got no rotch can get a homeowner's grand can resell the place. And you have local council fighting you.
So building cliffs was set up. To say to the mainstream person. Yes you can do it.
You've got the safety of private property. You have all the benefits of a socially conscious infrastructure.
So this whole life. Cried. You laugh. Middle class had no idea i think that that kind of.
You know that's a bit of nimbin hippy bullshit. That everyone around toed winter i know you've been around yeah ok..
I've got a t.v. I don't watch it all the time but i like to play the odd video. We like to drink.
Fruit juice we've got a mixer. We've got three panels out there.
I came here where i'd had a many lives before i came here.
In one nine hundred seventy five i was earning thirty two thousand dollars a year as a training officer.
I had a bit of break. It ran out rapidly. But you know we've got a few solar panels but.
There's no one here who hasn't got one tower panel. When i came when we landed here. Power source.
Was our car battery which i carried into the house and ruined a hundred to read indian.
Beautiful indian muslim and then i got two car batteries wow.
Oh i had one in the car and man in the house not yet the james and once a week. Nevertheless it's a bit of hannele.
Then to families. And stuff. But john. It was. Because we live like this it does not mean to say that.
There are certain things. These in technology that we don't one. I'm not afraid of technology.
I love it if it's appropriate. I'm not drawing. It doesn't take me four barrels of coal.
To fire up a bloody great pass to boil a cup of water in a day or something really interesting get a writ of death.
And that is. If mainstream. Isn't at the answers. It has to be didn't live like a q. It. You know that. Ok you say.
I've got to say this is just as wrong.
Now i'm not knocking will to block you've been saved because they have been a life raft for many people
and still are and still there will be. And as i said i know they've got their place. But as a social experiment.
It is essentially flawed. And the reason why. Communism is breaking down in russia.
Is because that old communist model of common ownership. Just doesn't work.
I'm not saying that it couldn't work in some idealist society. But in the here and now. On this earth.
It just doesn't work because there are some people who will steal who will obstruct who will be too paranoid to
participate. It falls apart is fall apart and seychelle to fall apart and melts land it fall apart and russia.
It's fall apart and in then.
Now it may well fall apart because i thought i was meant to push a good repartee along the good ones to collection.
But basically you do need some of that what you said was debt. Gentrifying establishment feeling.
We all need to have a base and i myself find. Private property. I have a problem with that notion.
I do believe in a lifelong lease of ownership and that's how i regard. Our tour and startle.
I don't know it's not like that but that's how i regard it.
We were originally set up here to lease delenn from ourselves and when we die. It goes back to the community. You know.
But that's not the system we work on but we're approximating it closely. There is nothing wrong.
In fact it is very necessary. To find that bridge between where you say no this is mine.
And where you say no i'm going to share here and. Mainstream society. Is overly too much in a head trip.
They get older right answers but no one can actually do without the fridge.
And no one can do without the infrastructure. So we flush our problems down the toilet.
And we just sayen wish for a better world. If you go to the multiple occupancies scene.
You actually live the ideal lifestyle.
But you can never actually said has fired those few basic needs that are coming up.
Every once in a while like you're dirt poor and your teeth fall apart on you or your marriage children part
and you can't sell your house and you're stuck. So you need an interim. Thing.
Where you have all the right philosophies that curry's came up with at the same time enough bite size of society at
large enough sense that it actually works on a human level as well. And i think that's what we've got.
I think we we're not saying we are the ultimate. We are a stepping stone from that. One way street. To nowhere.
The commune. You see that's what they try to do to us. They try to shut down a one way street.
And that's when we said no. And when i say that i'm not being derogatory about the places or the people.
They came at that time in the us. But they didn't spread. You know so really it was a cocoon trip.
Now we believe that the time is coming. Where we're going to have to spread. And we believe there will be places.
For like ours. You see my greatest dream is to see don a sixty year massacre of.
Is that took place through this big scrub. I would like to see a hundred year project. Say.
To read green the big scrub and. It would be done by the young guy who can do the work. It could involve kinda guy.
In and primary school through secondary schools and through our universities. It could.
Within ten years it would be such a major tourist attraction. That it would fund itself. Kids have got nothing to do.
Give them something to take them to the sunlight. And this. You were this lane.
For five years and replant it gives you the right to live on that. For as long as you live.
This is what we've got to do. And we've got to do it in a massive. Way and this big scrub area here.
Would be the ideal place to start. It would involve. Every religion every little town could participate.
And put their youth to work. But sell it to them and make it as popular as it is him in is in berkeley and you know.
Make them out of skinheads. The tree paintings. So we've got to let them go there.
Set them up with cameras let them have their music. Let them have a smoke and if they wanted. Not too much alcohol.
Like alcohol or who. I do see. Both.
Very very clearly a city the program that mainstream when you live in a place like this.
When you have people you saw a year or two ago.
Killing each other for the right to sleep in a public toilet in reality.
Kicked to death by a teenage girl for the right to sleep in a two hour. Our society. Actually creates. All this angst.
On the television you're being told that the ozone layer is falling apart and of. Job prospects and milk.
And yet you're being caged into this system. Close from close to collapse because when you want to go out.
You can buy the land. All the great. Revolutions around the world. All of them have been about ownership of land.
Make no mistake about it. Now to too much about land. The french revolution. Land it's all about land. And the land.
In australia today. It's menage to i should say mismanaged to. Old world concepts that are in essence saying.
The local inhabitant. Has no right to exist he's a supplement and. The local resources are get to be exploited.
We're now shifting into the twenty first century where we're saying expectation is over. Roads are in.
Timbers are made in the cabinets. Now we actually have to face a tree living here. We've got to change.
European dominated. Australian culture. To some extent what ever it is. Into a truly local culture.
And it's for that reason that when we built the model for. Bill and cliff.
Emotionally within ourselves we borrowed a lot from not only get rid you called it off the pacific islander culture
and niman and on a kind of untenable yeah.
And it's an interesting thing about this level of communism as to how deep you should go. Before you reach equity.
When you go to.
Original and have it and the lifestyle which are living today still in cape york and you know everywhere.
There is no one can.
Commoners and there is a chief who holds a certain large amount of land in trust for the population.
So when someone gets married. You get a bit of land. There is systems of ownership. Even operating on that level.
So we have the same systems here we must create the same systems here not what you say in the way belongs to everybody
and. He has been. The enemy from within. For us. A druid hard to deal with because i said to people out of three.
Our real problem.
On the outside has been overbearing system of the inside had to have been there were true thinkers who want to be left
alone you know one of the anarchists.
Can make more trouble than twenty one is ready and you know that i've always been a bit ikea's to myself.
So i could understand what you have to do you have to present the bill and clear. Whatever happens.
You have to go to the residence me
and you just if you want something to happen you just have to present a better case than the ones who don't want to
hear. It really is a low level democracy. We've got about seventy four families here.
We have a residence meeting once a month. The residents.
Make all the decisions about everything that meeting is usually attended by about ten. Residents.
A core group who are always there and odd ones who flock in because there might be a topic. From there.
So it's basically it's a business meeting. And it should be transplanted into suburban australia.
A church and of course a church. Of course through empowering neighborhood you've got to start talking.
And if you have people running around your neighborhood that are not doing anything.
Give them a job replanting cleaning the sidewalks up helping the old lady with her or her meal.
So we've come so bloody big in our system we forgotten about the little people and really once you start talking.
No matter how difficult that process is wonderful things happen on i go.
You know where the issues are contentious debate can get pretty heated. But if nothing else. We respect the chair.
I think in all the table years i've ever been here i've already attended one meeting where the chair couldn't control
to me and that was a little nasty. Politics. A pretty good. People who lobby. Get things done.
But if the majority of people don't think it's a good idea it doesn't get it. Were the acquired ideas twenty years ago.
You know couch mint came to new members and really was a way. He. He asked the question. If not one. Twenty five times.
He said. But what happened to all the ideals all these it. Young hippies are shy. You're all middle age.
You showed me any group of people in society you haven't changed in the last twenty years
and i'll say yes it's a graveyard. Everybody changes. Everybody. I also want to point out that that.
The aquarian ideal. Never was owned by newman. It was owned by. Everybody.
And it was in poland it was in amsterdam and was in california it was here.
We just made one shrine for you christ first of all nine hundred seventy three which allowed us trillions to have one
place to go to what it could sit and think about just wonderful phenomena that you actually are peaceful and organic
and sharing and so on and none of this is completely and all of us try to be a little bit.
So i see aquarius now everywhere to me when i look at the signing. It's very green. All.
Both philosophies which were expanded seventy three are now everywhere.
And i can be here
and happily talk about aquarius even though i wasn't here nine hundred seventy three i was in california i didn't come
here until seventy nine and. Yet i feel the same philosophy that i share with all the other ones that feeling that.
We are part of sponsible for the planet. And we optimistic one do something about it.
And with that ice i realized that within the bureaucracy from cambridge to perth sane people are supposed to put it in
a nutshell for me. The essence of the twenty years.
Is in the development of what you see when you drive around this valley. That's the aquarian to me is living. Strong.
Gratings gaining strength every day more and more people putting trees in more
and more people concerned about environmental issues. More and more people writing letters about matters.
And people get involved in the things that we have the day we didn't realize just what the problems were there in to
what we know now. We have a group of people here are very conscious of what's going on in the world.
I think that's my thing what i would have said. Well i'm not in seventy three years or twenty years hence now.
Yeah a man comes of age just twenty one days say orcon voted eighteen. I believe ukraine movement. Is getting of.
A good just getting towards its military stage. It's missionary stage you probably go out and.
And want to change the world for a little while and settle down and maybe ten years time. And at that time it becomes.
Mature philosophy. I don't quite i don't think. The i think the philosophy in fact is stretched from. Earth's.
Children who go and sit in the forest and climb up. Powell's probably.
To the other end of the spectrum which would probably be in the likes of a few.
Other cities around but we're not going to you if no one knows who we are so they can..
Well he says got to take the step on. From oz. I'm hoping it's a d. Devolution.
I would i would like to see now is that we have set this up. This can be done.
And we all know that the next one should be taking a bunch of young employed people out there and. Getting the desert.
To give for you it's just to get here the situation of debt. When you come of age.
In the pacific islands right off our front door here and man gets presented on marriage.
And he selected a partner with a house and a plot of land. That is that is an asset he gets. We are in our society.
Tell people you've got to earn it all from the beginning. And that creates poverty.
So it is a really good thing to look at our own processes and saying what are we really doing.
With with our world while. In fact why is the establishment. In effect. Trying to. Well. Choke the life out of.
One of the very few places. That actually tries to do what it. What we all know ought to be done.
However now we've said a lot of things about the lismore city council.
And i'd like to say one more thing and this is not by way of apology because what we've said has been absolutely true.
One individual. Drove us to distraction financially and emotionally in all sorts of way.
And he was allowed to do that by many of the med but. Three mayors ago.
We've gone through about seven men and five planners and christ knows how many engineers at all that.
Three minutes ago. We struck up a report with bob's. Who is in there. That time. And bob put us on the agenda.
And for that. We're very grateful to him as an individual.
Since then we've also had a lot of support from the past man.
And the crew and of our resident mayor john crowther that howell frederick's. So i really. In fact.
What they did to is early in the piece and ripped all our money off. In the end. They came good.
And given all that i was to get some more money. In fact. Fact and.
Should be said we when you reflect on that on the history.
You tend to get stuck and the big learning experience in the big planes and so on. It shouldn't be forgotten that.
Over the last few years we've become very effective in networking throughout the value layers of government.
And we found very good responsiveness denner of what's all the messages.
About why we're doing what we're doing are now understood by the average. Average bureaucrat.
And there are some visionaries when state local
or federal government to have really help in this along yet said yeah that must be said it's about did you do any other
kind of stuff you'd like to talk about. Yeah well yeah i know. They well they were all.
They were all the ones that are sorry. I didn't say they were the.
You couldn't repeat our team and to repeat the question. Sorry. Courteous movement. Was a bit elitist.
Because there is such a thing as a trickle down theory.
And you also find that the ones who had the notion the students did not were not the people who actually by
and large did. The telling of the story with their hands.
I think one of the nice thing that has come from aquarius one of the real growth. Things..
Is that has become a universal movement. What i wanted by the ph d. Or what i want to add more humble.
Occasional qualifications. What do you are a great debater or buddy you were a silent type.
What you were a mechanic over the. You know a nurseryman. It is right throughout the whole last yes.
The thing started with the intellectuals just like the nine hundred sixty eight revolution in paris. Also as a student.
Thing. You know that happens with students. But then it comes down. That's where you pay students for you know.
What do you think about lawyer.
I want to do doing nowadays in ninety three or what are you doing now
and i don't do much demonstrating well my daughter is too bloody busy going to work to support herself.
So you can go successful i actually frightened a lot of work that. All pretty well.
I tell you how we moved in here and my daughter was the first kid from here to get on the school bus.
And they used to leave iraq and seats around. And she had a very hard time.
For the first few months until she started learning a little bit stick around and telling few home truths.
However by the end of her first year at school she had started to move into leadership roles
and was being sent away on. Different leadership courses or. She's always been an excellent student.
And she's very motivated. Self-motivated because the university trip.
She has known since she was twelve that we couldn't afford to support. So in grade ten. She was the lions use of the.
And she did. More than any other. There's a big college. Arrives. And it's got the. Choice kids from all of them.
So there was a and for the other kids from this other college that she went through three of them.
She got the one from the state level so she did very well that year and at the end of grade eleven. She outtakes.
Award for all round. Excellent.
Although they did make a little bit of lassitude for her that allowed by eating to be recommences for them.
And in her final year she was a student of the year. So she was a particularly motivated go.
We have grandchildren grow up here and now. My daughter has three children of her and.
I'm watching my grandchildren grow up with an interest. Bringing kids up here. That was hard to.
I made a decision to come here. I suppose. And my family suffered and benefited for that. You know.